so last week our very own Phil argued
the need to get more excerpts I not only
agree with big Phil but I think this
needs to be extended to all men when it
comes to our education system as a proud
feminist and diversity campaigner I'm
often advocating for targets for women
in the workplace however I believe the
reverse is true when it comes to
teaching women make up 85% of teachers
in our nursery and primary school system
and nearly two-thirds at secondary level
this is a significant issue particularly
in inner cities where many boys don't
have a male role model in the home an
increase in male teachers could help
address the problems we have with white
working-class boys and black boys in our
schools celebrity schools such as LeBron
James is I promise Academy offer a 360
approach that tackles this issue but
also works with local families to help
raise aspiration levels of at-risk boys
as a woman I think it's time to set
targets for more men in our schools I
[Music]
could not agree with you more Jean what
I agree with you that we have male
teachers thank you the only thing that I
have an issue with and it's not
necessarily what you've been saying but
the wider debate around this I've heard
a lot of people saying the problem is
men aren't attracted to teaching because
it's relatively low paid it's relatively
low status and at the moment the
conditions for teachers aren't great and
that the especially early years teaching
is not being professionalized in a way
that has the kind of status now I think
that's all true but what bothers me is
if that's a problem then that should be
solved whether it's men or women doing
those jobs the idea that it's fine for
women to do Lopes at low pay low state
yet unrecognized
good work but if men if we want to get
men's do it we need to improve things I
have an issue with that you know I think
that we undervalue our teachers we
especially on devalue our early years
teachers here these are the most
important years of a child's life and
you know we're thinking at the moment
let's just roll with brexit we are at
the moment where we're trying to
reinvent ourselves what kind of country
do we want to be if we can't get it
together to invest in our young children
then I
have no hope for us and I think these
are the conversations we really need to
be having about our future well thank
you ever thank you I was not expecting
that at all I was gonna get and I've
definitely not aunty what children
actually really feel inspired by what
you said no I don't I don't usually
endorse quotas I am what dogmatic about
that I'm not dogmatic I understand you
know if an emergency situation is needed
but I don't usually go for quotas but
the spirit of what you're saying is is
really really important and and that's
what I want to endorse because I'm of
the teachers that inspired me most and I
was expelled as well at the age of 16 17
from further education college from East
am-noon college
I was expelled and then my mother put
her foot down because I left home at 16
she put her foot down and forced me and
I'm glad she did to go to sixth form in
a grammar school and the three teachers
that stood out til this day that I
remember were all male but I was able to
relate to them they inspired me and the
best results I had got in my education
up until that point came from the
attention that they gave me and
interestingly they predicted me grades
one of them an A for economics and and I
got exactly what I was predicted though
I didn't believe I would because I
didn't want to let them down so it
really can make a huge difference in
inspiring young boys because you can
relate to these men that are you know
teaching you how to grow up basically
you know a young a young man growing up
with a young lad growing up was go to
aspire to be something and he needs to
see what it is at the end of the rainbow
I mean so therefore he needs a man who
could stand and go this is this is where
you're going wrong and it's all right
he's gonna make his own mistakes in life
sure but he's got to see you know and
when you're talking to someone that's
been there seen it done it as a role
model or a mentor he can advise you on
the mistakes you can tell you when
you're going down the wrong path bring
you in I just want to look at some of
the stats around boys a kids being
permanently excluded from our schools so
in 2016 to 2017 6035 boys were
permanently excluded from 1685 girls and
I do think this has something to do with
the issue we have around
toxic masculinity and boisterous
behavior and I think there are a lot of
and I'm not at all knocking our female
teachers of course not but I do think
there are a lot of teachers female
teachers who are perhaps intimidated by
that sort of behavior from boys that
male teachers would deal with
differently so I think a few different
things on this I'm not a fan of the
education system as it stands today the
schooling system so it left my own
devices I would really like to shake the
whole thing up a locks I don't really
think it's often fit for purpose I love
that I promise school I think it's
absolutely wonderful what they're doing
I'd like to see more of those kind of
things existing so that's the first
thing I think the second thing so that
the the gap the biggest gap is in the
early years as we've just been saying
between men and women and you know
there's still a lot of rules within
early years teaching which is paying
minimum wage and that really horrifies
me because I think this is such an
important or it should be a very
important and valued skill set to have
that we shouldn't be paying people
minimum wage however I think that
there's also a stigma I think we need to
be really honest about men teaching
early year children and what I mean by
that is I know someone I won't name him
he is exceptional with young children he
engages with them they relate to him
they play they they've he's exceptional
and I said to him not that long ago you
should get into teaching you'd be
absolutely amazing and you know his
response was no way people are think I'm
a pedophile that was his response and
you scrunch your faces up that is it's
still a stigma that exists it is when
you see a man teaching young children
there are some people that would feel
uncomfortable I wouldn't I think that's
true I mean if you think about nannies
you know how many people do you know you
have a male nanny not many and there are
there are many nannies and and often
parents won't hire them because I think
there are people are more concerned
about many more about the school leaver
type child you know I mean I've mentored
a young Russian there he was about 15
years old he was find it very these
parents were multi-multi-millionaire so
when out of Switzerland I thought like
looked after him a little bit you know I
mean that was almost in a nanny role but
for a teenager I mean he couldn't call
it bodyguarding but it was classed as a
mentor in type role and it's it's those
ones I think with where the male's can
most involved when they develop when
they come into making their final
decisions in the in their development
and you can point them in the right
direction then granted I don't think I
have a lot of connection with the
toddlers do not mean I'm great for not
be grandkids and all that sort of stuff
but I don't have that connection at that
of those agencies when they a little bit
older than the Braun James is I promise
good funny and wonderful assesses adults
we have a responsibility to not let
these kids down to continue to be the
teachers the mentors to parents the
coaches the life studies the life skills
whatever it is the inspiration the
superheroes everything that's our
responsibility well I mean honestly and
I'm talking about attracting more men
men to these jobs the opportunities and
the quality of the profession itself
need to be looked at you know teaching
like all other public sector staff have
faced cuts they are overworked and often
underpaid and of course to attract young
men to this I think some some should
bring you enough there's been schemes
that have worked so in New York there's
the I teach New York New York men teach
and that was designed to get more
african-american men into teaching and
actually what we need is an approach
similar to that here but also to get
more white working-class men into
teaching and I think it's about
targeting the groups that are out right
there is a particular issue around race
the statistic I have is that last year
only 2.7 percent of male teachers were
black so for black boys there is a
particularly chronic deficit of male
role models that they're encountering
school and black men I know actually
often mention a male teacher even if it
was someone that wasn't their teacher as
being someone who had a huge impact one
of those teachers that helped me is now
the headmaster of the school and I got
till this day and I will go back to that
school when they ask me I'll cease
Westcliff higher grammar in South End I
go and I get I'll give speeches and it
just it's a lifelong impact that you
never forget because it can have a
life-changing consequence to your
direction and I just quickly bring in
though and when it comes to head
teachers a lot of them are men there's
only 38 percent of head teachers that
are females that we we do have met
at the top in the headteacher rolls and
my teacher was a man my favorite teacher
hey it's gone total at school but mr.
Melvin was my business studies teacher I
loved him don't remember him now